my apologies for enemies pronunciation
and ida is working in
i think mixed integer programming
linear and non-linear which is an area
that maybe has had not so much
interaction
with the sat community is my impression
but i think there is
lots and lots of room for for
learning from each other and having
interaction both ways so this is a this
is a very exciting seminar
to end with uh aida is at lehigh
university and before that was it
rutgers
uh university of texas at austin
and has also been at ibm um and has a
phd from
carnegie mellon but again the purpose of
this talk is not for me to waste time on
your
cv uh but to say
warmly welcome we're extremely happy to
have you and the floor is all yours
well thank you very much jacob for the
introduction and thank you ambrose and
jacob for the invite
as jacob already said i'm an optimizer
so uh i have given this talk
um to that the community of
uh nonlinear mixed integer integer
programmers before but this is the first
time to give it to a more
scs theory type community so because of
that
i would really um provide as much
material
basic material as you know you i
i think it's proper but you should feel
free to stop me at any point if i say a
term which is not clear or
you should um yeah so i haven't left a
few slides uh
like white in the middle of the slide so
that i can use that
uh to write on and explain as needed
all right so this is a work on binary
polynomial optimization
uh and this is joint work with alberto
del pia from
university of wisconsin at madison all
right let's start
okay
so let's start by defining a
multi-linear polytope
so a multi-linear polytope is a set of
binary points
z let me see yes
uh that such that they satisfy a
collection of multi-linear equations so
what is a multilinear equation
is just this expression here is the e
equals
product of some zvs so let's look at an
example right away so here for example i
have a multilinear set
so a multilinear set here you can see
that i have a
equation z12 equals z1 times z2
z24 equals z2 times e4 z123
z1 times z2 times z3 z134 z1 times z3
times c4 uh and these are binary
variables
okay and then we let the multi-linear
polytope to be the convex hull of a
multi-linear set
um in a special case so you see here for
example i have a bi-linear
the first equation i have a bi-linear
term then i have another bilinear term
here i have trilinears
and i should also say whenever i say a
multi-linear term
i refer to a product of some variables
so
this is just some terminology here
this is just called a multi-linear term
in the special case when i have a
product of two variables i
call that a bilinear term okay so in the
special case where
all these uh multilinear terms are
bilinear
multilinear polytopes becomes uh boolean
quadratic polytoe
this was uh introduced first by patberg
in 1989 who is a
famous person in integer programming and
later was studied uh by many other
people this polytope was introduced uh
to study
uh binary quadratic programming
and i will explain more about it and you
can show that this political
uh is a pretty much uh equivalent to the
cut political
via a one one to one transport mission a
political debt is studied in conjunction
with the max cut problem
okay either just a question since we're
doing the setup now
so should we also be interested in like
linear sums of these
z12s and z2 force
yeah yeah i get to that very quickly yes
okay and you will see why
so yes yeah but we can think about
okay the the like z123 i can think of
that either as a new variable or just as
a
monomial of degree three so basically
you can think of it yes as a new
variable and i will tell you
like immediately why i defined this set
in the way i did
okay i'm just uh
you know engaging in this exercise of of
making
as we translate between communities that
you know i mean we also have names for
these things we'd set it up
probably slightly differently but just
to make sure we're on the same page but
so far i think i think we're all good
okay good
all right so why did i define it the way
i did
let's just answer to jacob's question
here is a motivation
so i'm looking here at an optimization
problem
where i'm maximizing a linear
combination
of a bunch of these multilinear terms
right so it's a sum
c cs are some scalars positive or
negative and then i have
some multi-linear terms here i'm also
allowing for some of these variables
with binary and some of them even to be
continuous
okay so i i claim this is
a important optimization
problem so it already substitutes
several types of difficult optimization
problems for example
the one that you are probably most
familiar is when i don't have any
continuous variables in this case this
is called
pseudobolian optimization unconstraint
binary polynomial optimization
and also on the other end of the
spectrum when all the variables are
continuous this is usually called
you know this problem is maximizing a
multi-linear function over a box it is
again
well studied by people for example in
mixed internal linear programming or
global optimization
okay so let's say this optimization
problem is my starting point
so in although i would say a few words
that
what i'm going to talk about is even
more general than this problem but for
now let's suppose this is optimization
problem that i like to
attack so we already well we know
already this problem
substance abrupt np-hard problems okay
so
one common technique in the optimization
community is to learning
is to linearize the objective function
by introducing these new variables d
so i introduce a new variable z for each
multi-linear term
which is again just a product of a bunch
of variables
and then i linearize the objective
function as you can see here and i move
these non-linearity non-convexities all
to my physical set
so now you can see that my feasible set
is nothing
but the multi-linear set so now i'm
dealing with the pro
with the optimization problem which is
minimizing
a linear function over the multi-linear
steps
and also one thing that i wanted to
quickly mention
is uh in non-convex uh optimization
global optimization mixed integer
non-linear optimization so this
um technique that i said which has
different names like
factorable programming lifting etc it's
uh
fairly common and for example goes
the takes um the applicability of
multilinear sets beyond this
multi-linear problem that i showed you
but i tell you what i mean by that
so let's say i have
an optimization problem of the following
for let's say i'm minimizing
z1 square z2 squared
z3 plus z1 z2
minus let's say z1 square
z4 and let's say they are even
continuous variables
so let's say they are all defined over a
box
so when you look at this problem it's
not in the framework that i
mentioned right because you don't um
these are this is a polynomial
optimization and the variables are
continuous therefore it's not equivalent
you cannot replace let's say z1 square
by z1
so what do we do in non-convex
optimization so we
again in this case we start by
introducing new variables for these um
non-linear terms so i do the following
so i define
let's say z5 equals z1 squared
z6 equals z2 square
and then z7 is now
z5 z6 z3
z7 equals z1 z2
and z8 equals
z5 times d4
so now you are looking in a space
of well now eight variables and then you
can see that now your objective function
becomes linear now you are minimizing
say
um z6 plus z7
minus um z5 z4 z8
subject to these set of constraints
right
so now of course the next step would be
well what do i do with that
now i tell you a bit but you already see
that
even though in the original space
you couldn't see how i could use how
could i see a multi-linear set in this
lifted space you can see that these
equations
correspond to a multi-linear set
so this is to just um
motivate that understanding the
uh structure of the convex hall of
multilinear sets which again it's the
multilinear polytope helps us to solve
optimization problems beyond those that
in the original space
even look like what we expect and this
technique that i just described here
this is called factorable programming
pretty much any general purpose mi nlp
which stands for mixing journal linear
programming solver
relies on this technique can i ask a
question since this is the tutorial
again like suppose i'm given
a fully boolean a zero one valued
problem but with multi-linear
terms i guess what you showed us on the
previous slide shows that by just
having these extension variables i can
actually write it
as a 0 1 linear problem
and then so i guess i could then run my
favorite integer linear programming
algorithm on that is that what like is
done in practice or you
would you do something different or
smarter so
what i showed you in the previous slide
is that you do this
um extra so you do this lifting and then
the feasible set is the multi-linear set
so now yes you can do one step
sorry i guess my point is that these z
these constraints on z
you've written them as multiplications
but it's it's fairly easy to write them
as linear constraints
also once we're using the the
booleanness right
yes i could think of this as an lp if i
ilp if i wanted ions yes so this is
actually the subject of the rest of the
talk so
that is indeed the starting point the
problem is that
when you do that linearization so how do
the integer
let's say milp solvers solve that
so they have this branch and cut
framework right so
um let's say you want to get a bound
lower bound here you solve the lp
relaxation of that problem now i'm
getting ahead of the thought but the
problem there is
i mean um the answer is so
the lp relaxation is weak i think the lp
you are thinking about which is obtained
by simple
linearization of this product is weak so
yes
you can indeed input the problem that
way
but it will take a while so
the purpose of this talk is to actually
give you better
relaxations ah exciting
yeah okay all right
okay so yeah so as um
jacob already pointed out we are we have
this some non-convex problem
so you can think of it let's here for
simplicity let's say
i'm minimizing a linear function over a
non-convex
it's not really for simplicity it's as
difficult as it can get
but let's say look at this picture
so what would i do well we all know
if we take this non-convex set and
replace it by its convex hull
the we obtain a convex optimization
problem whose optimal value is the same
as this non-convex problem
now that is not much of a help because
constructing that convexal is
fairly difficult solving that new convex
optimization problem
could be fairly difficult because for
example if the original problem
is mp hard that convex hull doesn't have
any polysize
um representation etc
so what do we do in let's say non-convex
optimization
we say well the convex hole is difficult
to obtain let's settle for some
convex relaxation of this non-convex set
which is
not as tight as the convex hull but easy
to compute
and which you can optimize over
efficiently let's say instead
i take this polygon
okay so it's obviously a convex
relaxation of this saturn now if i
minimize
over this polytope instead in this case
let's say i get this point which is not
um
feasible to the original problem but you
get i get a lower bound on the optimal
value of the original problem so then
the idea is okay now if i can come up
with some
type of iterative scheme such that i i
can get
these tighter and tighter convex
relaxations
i can put them in some kind of iterative
scheme let's say branch unbound method
and finally i would converse to the
optimal value of the original problem
so that's the idea now
it's one import and there are many
things that go into this you know how
would you
so let's say if you are doing
minimization okay how would i do lower
bounds how would i do upper bounds
how what would i branch all these kind
of things would
impact the performance of the solver
but here we are interested interested in
the lower bounding step so the lower
bounding step
what we are interested in is to be able
to construct
these convex relaxations
that are cheap to compute you can
optimize over them efficiently but also
the bound that you get are not bad
okay so that's really the overall goal
in the convexification business
so in this stock we are interested in
the case where this non-convex set is a
multi-linear set
okay so before um getting into the
convexification part let me just
introduce this hyper graph
framework that i'm going to use so it
turned out that there were
there was a lot of interesting material
from
the hyper graph community
hyper graph theory community that you
could actually use them
to study these multilinear sets so how
would i model a multilinear set by a
hyper graph
well as you may already guess for each
variable zv for each independent
variable
i define a node and then corresponding
to each multi-linear equation
i introduce a hyper edge so again let's
get back to our previous example
i have z1 to z4 that which are my
independent variables so i have four
nodes here three one two three four
so for the first equation z12 equals z1
times z2 i put this
h12 here then z24z2 times z4 i
input this other edge for the tri linear
i have this hyper edge one two three
and for the other tri linear i have this
other hyper edge
okay and you for those of you who for
example have looked into max scott or
binary um quadratic programming you've
seen that you know this
people use graphs to study those
problems all the time and indeed this
hypergraph representation in case that
you're looking at
bi-linear sets just simplifies to the
graph representation that
people like pathway and others have used
to study
the boolean quadratic polygon so here
you can see an example there
okay so now what do we do with all this
okay so
when uh so this is like a general
practice
again in non-convex optimization when
you want to study
some non-convex set when you want to
study the facial structure of its convex
soul
so you start by con constructing a basic
relaxation
simple one let's say already jacob
mentioned it in the case of multilinear
sets
so you look at
each individual product right
so what is the feasible set here
is obtained by intersecting all these
equations
but now let's take each equation in
isolation
and then let's say i look at an equation
of the form z12 equals z1 times z2
where z1 and z2 are binary
if i just look at the at
this guy as my non-convex set
then we know how to construct a convex
cell indeed in this case the convex cell
is given by
z12 less than or equal to z1 c12 is less
than or equal to z2
z12 greater than or equal to z1 plus z2
minus 1 and z1 to greater than or equal
to 0.
so this is the this has been known for a
long time and actually it's not
difficult to show at all
so similar to this you can so this was a
bilinear but you can
easily extend this to
any product so let's say if i look at
the generic product like here
the convex cell is given by
e less than equal to z v
for all v in e
z e greater than or equal to zero and z
e greater than or equal to summation
zv v in e plus cardinality e minus one
so this is and then also okay and also z
v
less than or equal to one for all v
okay so these few linear inequalities
uh give you a convex hull of a
set defined by a single multi-linear
equation
over uh the set of binary points okay
and also we know that the convex follow
the
intersection of convex health is a super
set of convex all of intersections
so if i use that technique to replace
each product by its convex cell one at a
time
i obtain a convex relaxation of the
multi-linear set
so this is called the standard
linearization
um it also has other names you know like
in the case of
bi-linears who may have heard of
mccormick inequality so
people have studied this that uh this
polytope in the past um actually started
maybe not so much
studied but used it as a way to
construct bounds for um
let's say binary polynomial optimization
okay so now i have a
a convex relaxation as the starting
point
so what's next well
so one thing you can do is to ask okay
when is this guy
sharp are there any conditions under
which
this guy is a polytope
is indeed the multi-linear polytope
um and if not
when those conditions are not satisfied
how can i
tighten this one okay so this is the
question
now when we looked at this project
original
initially when i was in um ibm
um this was only answered or this was
already
only studied for bilinear sets so again
in the bilinear if all these products
are all mounted linear terms are
bilinears
multilinear positive is the boolean
quadratic polytope this has been
studied first by padburg and then by
many other peoples
okay so one of the first questions had
berg
asked was well when is the standard
linearization
sharp when does it coincide with the
boolean quadratic
the case of quadra
again he was a studying binary quadratic
program
and the answer is well it is exact if
and only if the
graph is acyclic okay
good so for example if i'm looking at a
bilinear set which is of the form
z12 equals z1
z2 z13 equals z1 z3 if this is all i
have
with this graph then i know what the
convex hole is
and it has this very nice
compact representation so this tells you
you know yeah if you're
uh the the underlying graph is a tree
for example
then the problem is polynomially
solvable
right okay then what if it's not a tree
well what would be the simplest
structure
um that doesn't satisfy that well let's
look at a triangle
right so what happens
if my multi-linear set is z12 equals z1
times
v2 z13 equals z1 times v3
and z23 equals
z2 times e3 okay so if this is my
set um what would be the
let's say the the convex hole in this
case so
it turns out that in this case okay if i
consider the standard linearization
it is not the convex hull y for example
i can look at the point where
every all of these guys are equal to one
half
so if i look at the point where z1 equal
to z2 equal to z3 equal to
z1 to equal to z1 3 equal to z23
equal to one half you can easily check
that this
half integral point satisfies all the
inequalities that are made
in standard
linearization now
let's see so it's the right point
this may not be the right point but okay
so
let me not um maybe confuse about this
so the point is the following
so what you do is the following so if
you want to look at
so what you do is you write down all the
inequalities
that are in the standard linearization
you look at the vertices
of the corresponding polytope and then
you see that those
vertices are there also points that are
not
zero one valued okay then you try to
come up with inequalities
that cut them out so what do i mean so
let's say
this is the political i'm interested in
and then let's say this is my original
relaxation
so what what i want to do
is to tighten this relaxation
so if you give me a point
like this which is in the bigger
polytube but then
also you can give me an inequality which
is valid
for my for the target for little let's
say you give me this inequality
and then i can show and i can check that
this point
is violated violates this inequality
then by adding this inequality
to my original relaxation i'm improving
it
i'm improving my relaxation so that's a
technique to improve
a relaxation okay so in this case in
case of a triangle
you can actually show that you can add
what we call triangle inequalities um
which are of the form let's say for
example z12 plus z13 less than or equal
to z1
plus z23 and there are three more of
them
if you add these triangle inequalities
to the standard linearization
then you get a convex hole of a triangle
okay so i gave you a family of
inequalities
so there are always the steps are as
follows you need to show that those
inequalities
are valid for your multi-linear set so
they don't cut off any feasible solution
to the original and convex set
so you sure they are valid you also show
they cut off some points that are indoor
in the week relaxation you add them
so they improve and then the next step
would be
you show conditions under which they
give you a new um a better
a better representation for the comic
sale of course that's not always true
you could
come up with these inequalities that
improve your relaxations there
and they never give you convex cells
under better
conditions but in this case what pattern
did was
at first he showed if you have this
learner linearization
in case of bilinear sets it gives you
the convex cell if and only if the
graph is acyclic then he introduced
these triangle inequalities
you should in particular in this case
they give you the convex hull of a
triangle when you add them to the
standard linearization
and also you showed more than that you
showed that
um they indeed if you add all those
uh all such inequalities to the standard
linearization
you get the convex all for um when g has
uh
no k for minor or it's called also a
series parallel
graph now in this case uh it's a bit
more interesting than the just the
standard linearization because the
inequality
actually i just showed you for a
triangle but actually you can write them
for
any cordless cycle and you need to have
them for all the cordless cycles in your
graph so in that case for example
you have exponentially many of them but
you can show that actually you can
optimize over them in polynomial time
and this is something i come back later
it has to do with
separating separation versus
optimization
i talk about it later but um this was um
just to tell you like the flavor of the
results so this
for example tells you yeah if now your
graph has a certain structure
so now you are allowed to have triangles
you have a lot to have cycles
but now if the graph uh is a serious
parallel graph
still the corresponding um zero one
quadratic optimization problem can be
solved in polynomial time
so now that by itself is interesting
from and you know just complexity
um theory kind of view point of view but
for optimizers perhaps there's even an
um
more useful tool that is given here
so when in the process of let's say
proving that
this problem can be solved in polytime
we introduce odd cycle
inequalities or triangle inequalities
those guys can be used
to improve the lower bounds inside any
let's say
mip solver or binary uh polynomial
um optimization solver
that can be those guys just it's true
that
for general graphs they are not enough
to give you the convex hull
but if you just add them
you can get better bounds and indeed and
better bounds mean
faster convergence for general problems
right
and indeed for example these triangle
inequalities have shown to be very
powerful for general
mixed integer quadratically constrained
quadratic programs
so there are solvers for those those
inequalities are implemented there
and they have shown that they expedite
the convergence quite a lot
there's a question in the chat from ryan
williams can you clarify what you mean
by a series parallel graph there are
several
in the literature yeah so this is a
graph with no k4 minor if i'm not
mistaken
okay thanks yeah
okay so yeah actually i know i said a
lot of things here but uh
you should ask questions if anything was
not clear
okay so yeah yeah so on that note
i guess i'll you know take you open up
on the offer and ask a question then so
like part of of why this is relevant is
if it happens that your graph is like
really really nice then now you have
something that is theoretically
in polynomial time but yes perhaps
equally importantly you're just saying
this sort of
indicates that this kind of if you add
some extra constraints that this could
buy you a lot
even if it your graph is not on this
very particular form
indeed so when you told me well i can
just do a linearization
and give that problem to a mip solver
what's the problem
well if you do that
again it depends on the mip solver but
let's say until even a few
years well actually i think even even
right now
if you linearize it and give it as a
meep
i should be careful because i don't know
what's going on inside ciplex but
the lp could be pretty weak but for
example
it's just a simple example if you input
it as
a in the non-linear way let's say you
put it inside
now stiplex does it too inside a
non-linear solver
solver they recognize these multilinear
terms
and then they start even for a general
graph let's say
it's not serious parallel so when they
look at the graph they recognize
cordless cycles they add odd cycle
inequalities corresponding to those
cordless cycles
to the lp solve that for lower bounding
and then they get better balance yes so
from a
um perspective of a and
let's say optimizers who do
computational up
so if you want to really solve problems
to global optimality
and they they are difficult problems
these kind of
inequalities are very useful because
they improve the bounds and i will show
you some numerical
results later and they yes they expedite
the convergence by a lot
and now i'm a bit out of my depth but i
know that people in the theory
literature
i mean on the theory side and i think
people in the audience would be more
knowledgeable than me but
on the theory side there we study things
like for instance
like systematic linear programming
hierarchies
known by names of surely adams for
instance that is somehow related to this
yes yes so
yes that's a very good question yeah so
let's say for example here ali adams
so they give you um a systematic way to
get the convex hall
of any yes let's say zero one polynomial
program
after a certain number of steps now the
problem is
and steps i mean just like level one two
three different relaxations the problem
is
when you get to the convex hall in the
extended space you can have
exponentially many variables and
constraints right
because you introduce many more
variables as you go on
the difference between this type of
study and that is that whatever we do is
in the original space
so i don't know how clear that is
but basically the inequalities are
generated in the original space now of
course
one method so surely adams for example
we use it a lot to so let's say we come
up with these inequalities in original
space
and then we argue if you add it to the
standard linearization you get the
convex hull
how can you prove that well there are
different ways but one is to
take you take the cheryli level and
relaxation that
that you know it gives the convex salt
you project out all the extra variables
and then you show that it coincides with
your set so the difference between
early is that this is in the original
space and because of that
um it's computationally feasible
okay thanks a lot no problem
okay so again yeah this was just to
motivate
you that when we looked at this problem
which is about multilinears uh
of higher degree than two there was all
this very nice literature on the
quadratic case
both in the context of the boolean
quadratic polytope or quad quality of
max cut all these inequalities
but nothing uh of a similar flavor
for higher degree multi linears and it
did if you also looked at the solvers
there well for quadratic programs so we
are still able to
um solve let's say those problems more
efficiently but we said okay let's try
to do a similar study for
multi-linear sets that contain higher
degree multilinear terms
and by again let's look at by looking at
these results let's just look at the
first one
the standard linearization is the
boolean quadratic point polytopic and
only if the graph is
acyclic okay what what what
would be a equivalent statement
or a statement of similar flavor
for higher degree multilinear sets
well just looking at this result so you
would think well okay
it makes sense to look at acyclic hyper
graphs right
and that's indeed what we did
okay so
at least for me at the time i was uh
perhaps not for you but for me it was
new to read about cycles in hypergraphs
and we found out at the time that unlike
the graphs that there's a you know
unique notion
of cycles and as cyclicity for
hypergraphs or
different types of cycles and indeed
there are different degrees of
acyclicity so
i have listed some of them here there's
burn just equilicity gamma cyclicity
beta cyclicity alphas essecity
and probably more so
um let me
just review some of the concepts
that are gonna be useful uh for this
talk you
i mean this is the part that probably
you know much more than me so if you
feel like i'm going too slow just
ask me to skip all right
so what is a birth cycle so a birth
cycle
of length t where t can be two or more
is a sequence of distinct nodes and
edges such that each v i
and v i plus one is in e
okay so the first thing here you see is
that oh you can't have a birth cycle of
length two
here is an example of a birth cycle of
length why is it a birth cycle of length
two well
here's the cycle we one e one two
we two even two three
and we yes and we won again
so this is the birth cycle of length two
indeed a birth cycle of
you have a very cycle of length two
whenever you have two edges that
intersect in at least
two notes okay
and then we say that a hyper graph is
vergacyclic if there are no burst cycles
here is an example of a bargestic like
hypergraph so you can see it looks very
much similar to a tree
so you can just take a tree in a graph
and
i mean it's kind of a fat tree so once
you have a tree
all you can do to now i want to go from
this to that
i can only insert nodes in individual
edges
so i can not do for example anything at
the intersection you see intersections
here
are very easy very simple have a very
simple structure right they can only
have one node
so this is a very acyclic hypergraph
okay so vertical simplicity is very
restrictive right
what would be the next type so we are
now going in increasing order of
generality
okay now we look at gamma cyclic
hypergraphs
so a gamma cycle is a burst cycle of
length
at least three so that's the first thing
i don't have a gamma cycle of knight two
the circle should have at least length
three
were all the nodes
but one in the cycle should belong to
exactly two edges so here is perhaps the
simplest gamma cycle you can think of
i have v1 e12
v2 e123 v3
e13 v1 so you can see here for example
v1 is a load to be in the intersection
of all three edges but the two
other nodes should be in exactly two
edges
now i claim gamma cyclic hyper graphs
are much more general than bridge acid
click ones
for example in a gamma cyclic hyper
graph you can have birth cycles of
arbitrary length
so here are two examples these are gamma
acyclic but you can see birth cycles of
length 1 3
okay here is another example of a gamma
cyclic hyper graph
now we can see for example in the
intersections i can have
more than a node so it can have a more
complex structure
but still a gamma cyclic hyper graph has
a very particular property
that makes it very um attractive to us
and that's the following okay um
i need to tell you what is a
stop hyper graph so if i look at
so here's my hyper graph g let's take a
subset of the notes
let's say the notes that are inside the
green edge i call
them v prime so the sub hyper graph
of g induced by v prime is the hyper
graph obtained by
intersecting all the edges of the
original
edge with this guy so you see this is
the
subhyper graph induced by v prime here
so you see for example here i have a new
edge added right so it's not like
typhoid graph can have edges that are
not present in the original hypergraph
so i also have now the side subhyper
graph of this um
like corresponding to the red edge to
the blue edge so now let's look at all
these guys
they all have a very particular
structure
so what that is is the following if i
look at
any two edges in any of these guys
they are either disjoint or one is a
subset of the other
right so you can see the same thing here
and here
so hypergraphs that have this property
are called laminar hypergraphs
so later on when i look at uh
convexifying
multi-linear polytopes corresponding to
gamma acrylic hypergraphs
this is the property that i'm gonna use
okay so this was about a gamma cyclic
hypergraphs
let's go one
degree more general so then the next
class
is the class of beta acyclic hyper
graphs
so a beta cycle is a gamma cycle
such that every node in the cycle
belongs to exactly
two nodes in the graph so remember in
the past
i told you in a gamma cycle
you can have one node that can be
present in all the edges
of the cycle but in the case of a beta
cycle
every node should be exactly in two
edges and no
other so now you can finally think of
the usual
cycle that you think of a triangle for
example is a better
cycle
and we have more examples here now
a hypergraph that has no beta cycles
it's called beta aclic
now you can see that metacyclic
hypergraph
or much more general than gamma cyclic
i do not have that laminarity anymore
so these beta cyclic hypergraphs have a
bunch of other interesting properties
but one thing that i just want
you to notice is that
if a hypergraph is better cyclic then i
can
always find an edge whose intersection
with the rest of the hypergraph is a
subset of
a single edge and that such an edge is
called a leaf
well beta cyclic hypergraph always has
at least one leaf so for example if i
look at the triangle that's not the case
right
if i look at any edge in its
intersection with the
rest of the graph is not a subset of a
single edge
and that is the property that i'm gonna
use later on
okay so this was uh what i wanted to say
about hyper graphite cyclicity
these are the one things that i'm gonna
use later
are there any questions
okay so i i'm guessing these parts are
probably familiar too okay
so now what i'm going to do is that the
question that the hyper graphs that you
have on that slide there or they they're
all
beta a cyclic ones so no better cycles
oh so these ones have better cycles so
these three
they have better cycles these are
examples of better cycles
this one is the right most one what
what's the
cycle i guess i'm still parsing the
definition okay
so would be v one
one six six
four six one two four well
i can write it down we won
we won e16
we well okay i i think it's clear what
i'm writing
um e46
then e i'm sorry
then b4 then e
1 2 3 4 and then v
1.
okay so if you want to see it
very clearly fix note 2 3 and 5 to 1
and then you get the triangle
yeah okay yeah yeah so these are
actually examples of hyper graphs with
beta cycles
you can find better cycles here yeah i
it wasn't clear here
this is an example of a hyper graph that
is fantastic
get it thanks all right okay
so remember in the boolean quadratic
qualitative case
standard linearization was the boolean
quadratic polytube went under
line graph as acyclic so
now i want to study um
multilinear polytopes of acyclic
hypergraphs
okay to do that i just defined
what it means to be an a6 like hyper
graph now let's get back to the business
of convexification
okay so to do convexification i will do
the following i will use the following
technique
again this is a bit more general than
this study but
not used much so one thing that is
nice if it's you can do is the following
i said if you have a set which is an
intersection of a bunch or a bunch of
simpler sets the convex hull of the
intersection
is a subset of the intersection of the
convex hulls of the individual guys in
general
so the two things are not the same if it
happens
that by intersecting the simple sets by
taking the
connects all of the simpler sets
individually and then intersecting them
you get the intersection of the convex
file that would be great because
that simplifies your life a lot so what
i'm saying is
if i have a set s
which is equal to s1
intersection s2 and suppose s1 and s2
have a
rather simple structure i can always
write
that the convex hole of s is a subset
well sorry okay yeah i can write that
the convex hole of s
is a subset of the convex hull of
s1 intersected
with convex hull of s2 this is always
true
now when equality holds that would be a
very desirable property
so why because then in that case instead
of looking at
s i can just look at s1 and s2 and
hopefully they are simpler
so if the equality holds we say
that this set sg is decomposable to sg1
and sg2
okay now to do
to tell you so what i'm gonna do here is
i
am giving you i will give you a
sufficient condition
under which i can say that a
multi-linear set is decomposable to
simpler sets
so once you have that condition
you can first decompose the hypergraph
and then
you go and characterize the convex hulls
of those simpler subsets
so this is the technique we are going to
use now
to give you this sufficient condition
unfortunately there is
a little bit of terminology i should
remind you so i just remind you that and
then we come and
i can parse that this theorem
okay so i already told you what the sub
hyper graph was
right we defined that one already so
there are two other things
um and again it's a bit uh confusing
because in
case of graphs this is slightly
different so we also have partial hyper
graph
and then we have also section i
paragraph
okay so what's the partial hyper graph
so if i have a
hyper graph g v and e
then g prime is a partial hyper graph of
g
so g prime with not say v
prime e prime if i have v
prime a subset of v and e prime
a subset of e so this is a partial hyper
graph
now a section hypograph is a partial
hypergraph
so if i have g prime equals again v
prime e prime
i have v prime in v subset of v
but then e prime should contain all
edges
in e that are
a subset of v prime so in the graph
literature we don't okay well subhyper
graph doesn't really make sense
in the way that we defined it then we
have sub graphs and induced sub graphs
right
so sub graph for hyper graph is a
partial hyper graph and then induce up
graph is a section hybrid error okay and
then then sub hypergraph is something
else
okay so i hope this is not too confusing
um okay and then one more thing
given uh two graphs g1
v1 this is the last notation i promised
g2
v2 e2 we defined our union and
intersection
as you may imagine g1 union g2
is just v1 union
v2 e1 union e2
and then intersection
okay so this is the terminology but they
just realized
we hit an hour do you want to take a
break or
do you want to do later maybe so what is
this a good time to take a break or do
you want to maybe
you know state the oh yeah let me just
make it here
yeah okay yeah all right okay so i gave
you all the
notation let me as jacob said let me
state the theorem
okay so let's say i have
a hyper graph g that is a union of
g one and g g2 and then
i make the following assumptions the
intersection of the
the two should be already
an edge that is present in the hyper
graph
and also for now i i will simplify the
statement let me just read it as is i
know it's not nice
and then for every edge in one of the
two
if it intersects with the intersection
it should contain it okay now let me
talk about the special case of this
because this is too much so
if i have two hyper graphs let's say if
i have two
so this for example says if i have two
graphs that
intersect in one node
so if this is g1 g2 this decomposes
for example if this is my original graph
i can just decompose it to two triangles
so this
initially for example gives you an easy
way of obtaining first fabric result if
you have a tree by this result it
decomposes to a bunch of edges
and then we know that those macromic
inequalities
give the convex help for a simple edge
okay but let's make it more interesting
so if two graphs
also intersect if the intersection of
two graphs
is an edge so here let's say g1 g2 the
intersection is an
edge they decompose
so this was for some examples for graphs
for a high paragraph for example
if i want to again think of a special
case of this result
if the intersection is a complete hyper
graph
then the things decompose so what that
means is if i have let's say g1
whatever it is g2 if they intersect
let's say
if this is my intersection
it's a complete hyper graph with three
notes it decomposes
so the case where the intersection is a
complete hyper graph that's
that's a special case of this result but
this result is more
general than that and well it is because
what i'm gonna need
um so what you only need to remember is
let's say here my hyper graph let's say
g1
is the blue g2 is the
green so their intersection
is these three nodes so the first
assumption says
there should be an edge corresponding to
those three nodes
it already is now this is not a big
assumption because there's
if there's no such an edge as and as i
will do later i just add it
it's the second assumption that is more
important the one that i've
written in blue so if i look at
g1 every edge
in g1 that has nodes
in g1 that is not in g2 either should
contain the red
edge like this one or should not
intersect with it
so for example i cannot have an edge
that looks like this
now of course this is only a sufficient
condition it is possible that what i
just draw is decomposable too
and indeed we don't know necessary and
sufficient conditions and the energy
composibility that very much
depends on the structure of the
hypergraph but here i'm giving you one
sufficient condition that i'm gonna use
uh for the convex hull characterizations
later
so when we come back from the brick i
will
use this technique to characterize
convex hulls for acyclic hyper graphs
but just to check that like the top
right green edge violates the condition
you want
or oh so you this condition is
asymmetric
it suffices for one hyper graph to be
sampled
yeah so thank you no problem
okay so i guess so you're saying that
now we should uh
contemplate this theorem for for a few
minutes while taking a break
or just relax a little or okay
we can um but before maybe even before
doing that are there any
questions from the audience you can type
anything you like in the chat even even
more nice if even nicer if you just
unmute and speak
any questions up to this point comments
excuse me can i hi can i
see again the definition of section
hypergraph
because i think i missed i mean i don't
have all these definitions in my
direction hybrid graph
yes it's a partial hyper graph that
includes all the edges
that are in that that are a subset of
the prime and are in the original graph
so it's like an
induced graph in the new subgraph
okay thank you so so is it correct that
a section hypergraph is a partial
hypergraph where you throw in
all edges that you possibly can exactly
yes you explain it
and then you have this other notion
where instead which is also in some
sense induced but once i
once i fixed my new vertex smaller
vertex set i just took the intersection
of all the edges
yeah so in subpar in a sub hyper graph
you can have new edges added right
because you intersect the original edge
set with that smaller vertex set
and that could introduce new edges in
the that are not in the original one
okay
as long as they are as long as they're
of size at least two so i guess for for
standard graphs like the the
sub this induced subgraph thingy and the
section hypergraph thingy they coincide
but
in general for large for larger edges
they don't
exactly yes yes okay any other
questions comments
will we take a break
when should we be back so let's take it
let's uh
take a break and let's be back 15
minutes before the hour
all right sounds good okay thank you so
much
so it's time to get back to the
talk
how are we doing
hello hi sorry i lost track of time i
think
just by a minute or two any questions
before we get started
do anyone otherwise i think we'll just
jump straight to it straight into it
again you can ask questions at any point
in the chat you can also just unmute and
speak
as massimo lauria successfully did just
a
few minutes ago um because i don't see
anything i guess we're
just getting started on the second half
please
all right so yeah we are pretty much
down
done with the background material so now
we can present the results
okay so just to recap
the very first question was
for a multi-linear set when is the
standard linearization
sharp when is it the same as the
multi-linear quality multi-linear
polytope is the convex hull
remember in case of graphs pad bird
proved that
the external linearization is the
boolean quadratic polytope if an only if
the underlying graph is acyclic
so our first result is as follows
the standard linearization is the
multilinear polytope
if and only if g is a burgestic click
hypergraph
remember bird just cyclicity is the most
restrictive type of escape
so how would you prove something like
this i just
give you a sketch of course not much
detail
but let's say we first assume that um
the hypergraph has a birth cycle of
length two remember that a birth cycle
of length two was nothing but two
edges intersecting in at least two nodes
so in this case i use uh the technique
that i
uh discussed before we first
give an inequality which could we claim
is valid for the multilinear set
why is it valid well
if you look
so again let me maybe i draw the
associated hyper graph
so it looks like this i have two edges
e1
e2 that they
intersect in at least two nodes
so the inequality sums over
all the variables corresponding to two
nodes that are in e2
but not in e1 plus
ze1 minus ze2
less than or equal to the cardinality of
e2 minus
e1 so the only way
this can be violated is if
everything here is one and everything
here is one
right so if everything here is one so
i'm saying that
all the nodes that are here are one
right
then i'm also saying all the nodes that
are in e1 should be one
for to make the ze1 equal to one but
then in that case
ze2 is also forced to be one
right so that is just a proof of why
this inequality is valid for the
multilinears
okay good so it is valid the second step
is to give a non-binary point
which we have constructed here we don't
need to look at exactly how it looks
like but
what is important is that
this point is in the standard
linearization
but it violates this inequality
okay so this uh
by this argument we conclude that if
there is a verb cycle of
length two then the standard
linearization is not
the multilinear poly two and indeed we
gave an inequality
to make that point clear
so now you assume that okay there is a
birth cycle of minimum
length which is at least three so i
cannot have air cycles at length two
that already simplifies things quite a
bit because when you say there is no
birth cycle of length two
you mean that all the intersections of
the edges should be at most one note
so in that case if there is a bird cycle
of length tree or so
after fixing some notes you will
end up after fixing some nodes to one in
your hyper graph you will end up with a
cordless cycle
okay and the reason you can do that is
because we already
took care of the birth cycle of length
two case so now we can assume that the
intersection of all the edges is at most
one node
so now that i have a cordless cycle from
oh sorry from pat what patberg did
before i know that in this case odd
cycle inequalities are facet defining
and the standard linearization is not
the boolean logic polito
and i can use that to show that in this
case
standard the standard linearization is
not the multi-linear molecule
okay so so far i have shown if there is
a birth cycle
then the external linearization is not
the multi-linear product okay
now i'd go for the converse so now
suppose that i have a bird jessi click
okay just
i just say i can't talk
sorry about this okay so now suppose
that i have a bridge a cyclic hyper
graph
i want to show that the standard
linearization is the multilinear polygon
in this case
so now i will use that decomposition
technique
okay so the first step is um
i'm relying on very good memory of you
at some point i told you
if i have a hyper graph which is better
cyclic there exists
always a leaf a leaf is a edge
whose intersection with the rest is a
subset of at least an
atmos and other edge in case of the
burgess cyclic hypergraph which is much
more restrictive than beta acclick you
can show something
stronger if you have a birch acyclic
hyper graph there is always an edge
whose intersection with the rest of the
hypergraph is one note
okay so again you can think of a leaf of
a tree in graphs
okay so now let's take a leaf
let's call that g1
let's call the rest of the hypergraph g2
okay so the intersection is a node that
is the very very very special case of
the decomposibility result
so i told if the intersection is a
complete hyper graph it's decomposable
and node is a very special case of a
complete um
hypergraph so by that decomposibility
result
i get that the graph decomposes to the
green graph
and the remaining now the remaining
itself is still very just a click so i
can use the same argument recursively
i find the leaf i use the decomposition
argument
i keep doing this at the end my original
hypergraph decomposes to a bunch of
hypergraphs each of which is just a
single edge
well then i'm done because i know the
convex hollow what of what a single edge
is exactly that's what the standard
linearization does
so by this argument i conclude that if
the hypergraph is very just cyclic
this literal linearization is the
multilinear fault
so any questions about this proof
all right then did you need to i'm just
not muting too slowly did you need to
pick the
edges in a certain order or was it true
that in fact like
any i mean or is it that no no two edges
can intersect
have an intersection of size two because
that would already be a cycle or no
that would be a birth cycle of length
two yes so
the hypergraph is the edges in any order
so not not in any order the only thing
you do know is if a hypergraph is very
just cyclic there exists and a leaf
so we just say okay there there exists a
leaf let's take the leaf
right so indeed for example i cannot
take
this edge as the first one right oh
because i want
to what's the point i i really i like i
want to
just have a i want to decompose into
leaves
not into like subgraphs that's why
you're picking off the leaves like one
at a time
yes so i want to use the decomposition
technique to get
a collection of guys each of which is a
single edge that's what i want to do
because that finishes the proof
okay so if you do if you let if you take
a leaf each time
you can just detach that single edge and
then on one hand you will have an edge
which is
just as simple as it can be and the rest
remains very drastically
and then i can do it again and again
okay
yeah yeah okay so now that's
this is nice because well because the
standard linearization has a very simple
structure
so but however where jessica click
hyphen graphs are super restrictive as
you can see
and i cannot think of any interesting
problem whose underlying hypergraph is
burgess click
all right so let's do then uh something
more interesting
so the next step as we
discussed in case of quadratic problems
is to introduce
a class of inequalities valid
inequalities for the multilinear set
that we can show they strengthen the
standard linearization
we add them to the external
linearization and then we
study conditions under which the new
relaxation
gives the convex okay
okay so now i i define this new class of
inequalities
so we call these inequalities running
intersection inequalities for the
reasons that will become
clear shortly so i will need to define
these inequalities i need to recall
uh what's the running intersection
property
now you guys probably have seen things
in different contexts i kind of
found it accidentally meaning we we
figured we need this property and when
we were trying to write it down
we found it already there and has a name
which is great so
um let's uh define it first um
so a set f of subsets obvious set v
has the running intersection property if
there is an
ordering of these guys let's say p1 p2
up to pm
such that if i take any pk in this
ordering
the intersection of pk with all previous
elements in this ordering is a subset of
a single element
so what i maybe i can
just give you an example right now
let me look for a
example right here okay
all right here it is
so remember i call those guys p i's so i
use the same so let's say i have p1
p2
p3 they all intersect in this one node
p4
p5 you know it's also i should say it's
it's a multiset it doesn't matter but
you can have identical elements we need
identical elements for later and then
okay so let's say these i have p1
so that multiset f consists of
these guys right pi's i from 1 to 8.
so i claim p1 p2
p3 up to p8
is a running intersection ordering of
these guys why
so okay so if i look at p8 intersected
with all the previous elements in this
ordering
i will get these in this case i will get
these two nodes
two nodes these two nodes are already a
subset of p7
good then if i remove p8 look at p7
intersect it with the remaining guys
i get this one node it is a subset of p6
good it satisfies p6 now i remove p7 v6
the intersection with the previous guys
is the empty set
that's good p5 the intersection is p4 p4
is the subset of p4 good
p4 the intersection with previous is
empty and you can keep doing that
to verify this is a running intersection
ordering therefore
f has a running intersection property so
this is the definition
and based on my very limited
understanding of this this was first
discovered in the databases con
community that they were using this to
define asics like databases
okay so why am i using this for
i want to introduce you a new class of
inequalities so to do that
i i i say the following i say
suppose i have an edge e knot that i
call it the center edge
and then i have a collection of edges
that intersect with
e naught in at least two nodes and again
that's
at least two nodes you already know
because if it's one node it decomposes i
don't care
but then i intersect enough with a bunch
of edges
that have at least two nodes
intersection with this guy
and then i assume this is the important
assumption that i need if i look at all
these intersections
so the set i'm interested in is just the
intersection of the center edge with
these guys that i call
neighbors that set should have running
intersection property
okay if it has it then i can write
an equality that i call running
intersection inequality
centered at e naught
with neighbors e k i must say there's a
lot of notation here so i really don't
want to go through the notation
i i just want you to have the big
picture that okay
this this was the kind of property i
needed so
if i have this property i can write
an inequality corresponding to it and
you already see
because of the structure that i assumed
you already can find
birth cycles of length two gamma cycles
etc there
so the point is you have a center edge
and a bunch of
other edges each of which intersects in
at least two nodes with this guy
and you need to for the set of
intersections you need the running
intersection property
if you have that you can write this
inequality
okay so usually for optimizers i go in
detail
and talk about how to construct these
inequalities but i don't think
how to construct them is much
interesting here i just want to say
one thing is you may think the way i can
write this inequality
depends on the specific ordering i pick
um and indeed there are multiple or
when you hover and in fact you can show
if there's running intersection property
there are multiple
orderings that you can write what
happens is
you can prove that any ordering you pick
if i you can if you write all possible
running intersection inequalities then
you see that that's independent of the
ordering
okay so the if so you can pick any
ordering
you write down all the possible running
intersection inequalities you can do
right where that's hyper graph there's a
that system is independent of the order
okay good so in this way these
inequalities kind of have a nice
well-defined definition now that i have
these inequalities
running into intersection inequalities i
define a new relaxation
for the multi-linear set so i here call
it the running intersection relaxation
this is the polytope obtained
by adding to the standard linearization
all possible running intersection
inequalities
so now we want to understand when this
relaxation
is tight when is it the multi-linear
polito
okay so here actually i don't have a
nice if and only
although now i will switch to a
different result that is very clean but
i just want to say
this is the most general result we have
that there's a gap here so what it says
is
if the hyper graph is not petacyclic
then the running intersection relaxation
is not the multilinear polytope
okay if it is that acid click
in addition you need another condition
which again it's kind of a technic it's
easy to verify it's something like you
don't you cannot have a structure that
looks like these three edges
that more or less look like this if you
don't have that substructure
then the running intersection relaxation
is the multi-linear polarity so
remember there's the class of
burgess cyclic gamma a cyclic
that has cyclic hypergraphs in
increasing order of generality
we already settled bird we said
yes our linearization is a complex cell
for emergency clique
now we introduced the new relaxation we
said
for a sub for not for all the better
acyclic hyper graphs but
for beta cyclic hyper graphs with a
specific property
which actually it includes gamma acyclic
so let's say for this
class so which is in between gamma
and beta the running intersection
is the multilinear polytope
is this even land leaf no so we know if
the hypergraph is not pathocyclic
then this guy is not the multi-linear
polito
we also know that i can give you an
example of a beta acrylic hyper graph
for which
the running intersection relaxation is
not the multi-linear voltage
however this sufficient condition here i
just want to um
stress it's only a sufficient condition
but at the end
what this tells you is there's a class
between gamma and beta for which the
running intersection relaxation
is the multi-linear polytope okay now
the proof of this
is fairly tedious and technical you'll
welcome to look at the paper
so instead of presenting that
i look i will look at a special case
where the result is clean
and the proof technique is
easier to understand and that's the
class of gamma acrylic hypergraph so
remember
we set old bird then we presented the
result that gives us something better on
gamma
not now i'm gonna focus on gamma
and settled gamma okay so it's the
special case of this
okay so now i'm looking at a
special type of running intersection
inequality so in running intersection
inequalities i was concerned with the
case where i had a center
edge and a bunch of other neighbors that
intersect
with the center edge in at least two
nodes and they also they intersect with
each other
now if i make this extra assumption
which says the neighbors cannot
intersect with each other
so this is how the graph would look like
then i get these inequalities that i
call flower inequality why did i do that
because
in the series of papers we wrote we
first studied these guys and then we
generalized them
that's why they have different names so
if the neighboring edges don't intersect
with each other
these valid inequalities become much
simpler
so we call them flower inequalities so
now i define the
flower relaxation to be the polytope
obtained by adding
all the flower inequalities to the
standard linearization
okay now we have this clean result which
says
the flow relaxation is the multilinear
polytope
if and only if g is gamma acyclic
right so gamma has cyclic hyper graphs
we have a
necessary sufficient condition here
for their convex a corresponding convex
file again what's the idea of the proof
it's kind of similar to burgess cyclic
that i said i just
go over it quickly because it also uses
the full
strength of the decomposition result i
show you
okay so let's first do the easier
direction so if there is a gamma cycle
then after um
fixing some nodes to one i will
obtain structure which is either a
cordless cycle
or one of these guys and then
that hyper graph is easy enough that you
can tell
the flower relaxation is not
the convex health for it and the way you
do it you just find the valid inequality
that is not implied by that relaxation
so this is one direction
the other direction is using the
decomposition
argument okay so i'm looking at a gamma
acrylic hypergraph
i have a leaf i'm also interested in a
maximal leaf what is a maximal leaf it's
a
leaf so it is at this edge that is not
contained in any other edge okay
so if i don't have if i have only
i assume i have at least two maximal
leaves if it's one it's settled for now
let's assume i have
two so let's assume so let's look at the
maximal leaf
so let's call this guy g1 g1
and the rest of the hyper graph g2 i
want to use the decomposition argument
so i look at the intersection in this
case the intersection is already an
edge so i'm good if it's not i will add
that edge
not a problem okay so the other
condition i need to check
is every edge in g1
either should that has nodes in g1
not in g2 either should include this guy
or should be
disjoint from it why is that satisfied
because a one result that i told you
that the sub hyper graph
of the gamma acyclic hypergraph is a
laminar high paragraph
and indeed this follows from the
definition of
laminarity okay so i can do the
decomposition so i
get this laminar hyper graph and this
other one
so the rest is still gamma acyclic
i go for another maximal edge you see in
this case now i apply the composition to
these guys now this is g1
now you see that this intersection is
not an edge i
introduce a new variable so i'm going to
a lifted space
so i add this edge i use decomposition
again i get another laminar
and the new gamma cyclic i keep doing
this
at the end i'm left with a collection of
laminar hypergraphs
so what that means is if i can
characterize the convex
of a laminar hyper graph i'm done
okay so
so far we showed after adding at most
let's say cardinality edges to a
gamma acyclic hypergraph we can
decompose it to a collection of laminar
hypergraphs
all right so what can we do with laminar
hypergraphs
so it turns out you can characterize the
convex hull of a multi-linear
of a laminar hyper graph directly
why is that um so we
use here a technique
from integer programming
and that is the following so
if i have a polyhedra defined
by system of inequalities i look at the
matrix corresponding to the coefficients
of those inequalities
if that matrix is balanced
then the corresponding
polyhedra is integral meaning that the
vertices are zero one value
so um you probably would ask me what is
a balanced matrix
so let me just define what that is
so is zero minus plus one matrix so the
entries could be zero plus minus one
is balanced
so if in every maybe i don't write don't
write it i just say it if in
every square sub matrix with exactly
two non-zeros parallel and per column
the sum of the entries is a multiple of
four
so for example if you can find a three
by three matrix where
the sum of the entries is six then this
is not a balanced matrix
so starting from the inequality
description of a polyhedra
with some extra assumptions that i don't
want to
bore you with that if
the corresponding constraint matrix is a
balanced matrix
then you conclude that that polyhedra
is integral meaning that the vertices
are 0 1 values
it turns out luckily
for if the hyper graph is laminar you
can show
the constraint make the constraint
matrix
the matrix corresponding to these
inequalities is balanced
and therefore that tells you this is a
convexal description of the laminar
hyper graphs
this is the result by converting
coordinates about
the connection between integral
polyhedra and balanced matrices so here
we really
were lucky to use this result that
enables us to give the convex hull
of multilinear uh to give a multi-linear
polytope of laminar hyper graphs
directly
okay am i done almost
the only one you remember in the process
of decomposition
i introduced some new edges as i needed
to
so in the last step you just project
them out
so you can for example use for your mod
skin project those extra edges
and then you can show that the flower
relaxation is the multi-linear voltage
so this is the way uh we prove it we
first
use decomposition get these laminar
hyper graphs they are very
particular you can characterize their
convex holes directly
using this nice result about balanced
matrices
at the end you project out auxiliary
variables that you introduced
and you we get the statement we need
well are there any questions about this
yeah i know i i skipped a lot of details
but um
for a mod skin is somehow that you uh
add up the inequalities to cancel out
certain variables yes yes so
you take a variable one at a time you
look at all the ones with positive
coefficient
all with negative coefficient and you
use them to you know project out that
variable
okay so i think if we're translating
this the sat setting
i mean if you're doing this on cnn
formulas i think we would
refer to this as davis putnam resolution
but this is something similar
but i guess for for integer linear
programs
or yeah for linear programs in general
okay okay great
all right so what you just said but i'm
just curious
so because this is only applicable to
linear systems is that more general
uh oh this is this is just an
observation that
that if you do exactly like if you write
the cnf formula
a formula in conjunctive normal form i i
mean you can just write it as a sum
sum of the literals greater equal one
right
and now as a zero one linear integer
linear program that's just the same as
the
original cn formula and now it's just
the fact that if you systematically
one variable at a time just add up
um all constraints with the variable
appearing positive and negative to
cancel them out and you do this variable
by variable
then you'll derive zero greater or equal
one
if and only if the cnf formula was in
fact unsatisfiable or not yeah so yeah
that is also indeed
to show if a system of linear
inequalities is feasible or not
of course it is kind of theoretical but
yeah so in this case you know
it's messy but uh you can use it to um
prove this in general it's obviously
it's like double exponential
so you don't do it yeah no it's not it's
not a good idea for solving either but
it's
my understanding is it's fairly powerful
as a as a pre-processing
technique as a pre-solving technique in
some limited settings but you wouldn't
use it
as a general method okay
okay so now let me say a bit about
so i gave you this polytope
the flow relaxation pulley over the
running intersection polytroph and i
totally told you when our data contacts
all
but how efficiently can you solve over
them
so actually if you look at the even the
flower one
if you look at the definition it tells
you
take a center edge and take any subset
of the neighbors
that they don't in such that they don't
intersect with each other and then you
can write an inequality
now you can think that if i have a
center edge and then let's say m other
edges that are neighbors
i can write of the order 2 to the m
flower inequalities and indeed you can
come up with the example
where all of these guys are facet
defining meaning that none of the
inequalities are redundant they are
indeed needed
to characterize the convex cell so that
tells you this polytope in general could
have exponentially many facets
however what you can show is that you
can solve over it
in polynomial time if the hypergraph is
gamma cyclic so what do i mean so
uh maybe you guys are familiar with this
but in case you are not
about um separation i just tell you
what do i mean when i say separation so
in this case
let's say i have a hyper graph g so g
is given
and a family of valid inequalities
for the multi-linear set
so let's say in this case flower
inequalities running
intersection inequalities so the
question is the following okay and
i i am also given a point z bar
let's say it's in the unit high part
so the question is whether this point
satisfies all those inequalities if not
give me an inequality from that family
that is violated by this point
okay so this is the separation problem
so it's defined for over a family of
inequalities
you give a point does it satisfy them if
not give me an inequality that is
violated by it
so what you can show is that if the
separation problem can be solved in
polynomial time
then the corresponding optimization
problem which is the problem of
minimizing
a linear function over those valid
inequalities
can also be done in linear time okay in
polynomial time
okay so the two things are kind of um
equivalent so
for what we can show
is the following so we can show that
if you have a gamma acyclic hyper graph
you can separate over flower
inequalities
in polynomial time what even though
the flow relaxation itself has
exponentially many facets
so that implies optimization
problem over gamola cyclic hyper graphs
is polynomial
now what happens is separating flower
inequalities over general hypergraphs
though
is mp heart so why is that important
remember
when i um motivate these things i was
saying well these results give you fully
time-soluble cases
but what you also like is to use those
inequalities
to improve the bounds for general
classes of problems
so this so far we said if your
underlying hypergraph is gamma cyclic
you are in luck even though you have
exponential limiting inequalities you
can do this
solve the separation problem over poly
time the optimization problem is
probably time
however if you have a general problem
and you want to use the flower
inequalities to sep
to improve it separation problem is
empty hard
so that's at the beginning it's kind of
a it's negative
however what what is the thing that goes
into the exponent and think
gets things bad is the rank of the hyper
graph
so what is the problem input maybe i
should have said that it's you know
it's uh so you get your hyper graph is
your input and you want to see whether
it's
polynomial in the in v
e and the rank of the hyper graph
now
what is happening is the rank is causing
all the trouble
so i will make the following assumption
i
i will say well and what is happening is
if the rank is fixed
then the pro then the separation problem
is uh
it's actually easy you can do it in
fully time now i would
claim this is not uh this is not a bad
assumption
why because in polynomial optimization
problems
well v is like the number of variables
e is the number of multilinear terms
they can be very big you can have
thousands of them
but then r the rank of the hypergraph is
just the degree of the polynomial
optimization problem
and oftentimes almost always that is
much smaller and indeed you know if you
go to
higher degrees let's say if it's more
than 10
and if you want to solve that problem
even like numerically the round of
errors will kill you it's not even
doesn't get to this point
so here we are gonna assume the rank is
fixed
once you assume the rank is fixed then
the separation problem not only over
flower inequalities but also over the
most general class which is the running
intersection uh
inequalities can be solved in polytime
so what we do is
we devise some separation algorithm
based on a variety of
um heuristics and ideas to just solve it
efficiently
okay so
i show you some numerics but this would
be
the time if you have any questions about
um
anything theoretical so far
i'm a little bit curious how dependent
the the these characterization results
are to
which which kind of linearization you
perform
uh like i don't know uh if you can see
in the chat it's kind of hard to read
out the math but there are like
um like if if i want to say that
um if i have a monomial of degree
four and i want some variable that
encodes that all of these four variables
are true
then i guess i could write like four
constraints
saying that if my new variable z is true
then this forces x1
to true and then another similar
constraint for x2 and x3 and x4
or i could just write them as a i think
this is called the big m constraints
like minus 4z plus all of the x's
greater equals zero uh
and the question is like if you start
playing around with aspects like this
would this make these affect these
results like in a
major way or would it be more of a
technical nuisance but the end result
would be kind of the same
so in in if i understand your question
correctly in
the things that i discussed there was
so big means yeah it's a different story
yeah and as you said
the way you linearize will change the
quality of the relaxation
okay here there's not such ambiguity
though so i gave you exactly what is the
relaxation right so
given this linearization this is the
result so
yeah and i guess yeah so i'm trying to
change the linearization
oh yeah for sure it will change the okay
it will be like
then it's like oh then we have to start
over from the beginning and see
so yeah you are looking at a different
political potentially right
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah
um which also i guess raises the
question of like
that you could potentially play around
with all kinds of different
linearizations and see if
so i think one thing that you may want
to say is the way you write your
multilinear function is important
because you know how like there are
multiple
ways of writing right like um
in a like they call posey form
i'm trying to remember the things that
like uh in pseudo-boolean optimization
you can like write you know as the sum
of some one minus some you let
x some one minus x there's not a
so given a bunch of binary variables
you can bind binary points 0.1 points
are different ways of fitting them to a
multi-linear function right
yeah so yes that the way you there are
sums that are better than others because
based on how you choose what that multi
exact multilinear function is the hyper
graph will change
and finding the best way to write that
that is a difficult problem
i don't know how much you followed but
it's like based on which variable to
switch and which not
okay but i guess the reason you the the
standard linearization is called
standard is that
that you guys like it oh
well the reason is called stan well it
was called the standard like four years
ago by a guy
and they followed um but what i wanted
to say was that's after the step i said
because i'm already assuming at this
point
i have some of a bunch of multi-linear
terms what i was trying to say was the
following
you can first switch some variables so
let's say replace x by one minus x some
of them and then
then call them new variables and then
have it in the multi-linear form i have
so that's extra pre-processing changes
the problem
okay so for example you know the thing
that
well if i have if i have a multi-linear
functions a
sum of products if all linear
combinational products
let's say i'm maximizing if those
coefficients are all non-negative
then this is a super modular function
and the problem is easy
now you can give me a multi-linear
function then it's fully expanded form
it's not super modular but then by
switching a subset of variables you can
get a super modular function
and if i believe that problem is empty
hard um
so that's what i was saying it's you
know the way you write that
expression what variable to switch
versus what not to
that um changes the hyper graph that
changes the difficulty of the problem
but once you settle that okay
once you settle on the multi-linear set
once you tell me this is the
multi-linear set
that i have a hyper graph for then the
complexity of this
linear linearization is not a function
of really
how to choose things it's fixed at that
point
i see okay thanks no problem
um okay so maybe let me show you some
numerics
um so this
uh i i show you two uh the first is here
we just generated
a collection of random optimization
problems
there are polynomial optimization
problems of degree three and four
um variables are even continuous uh
so you do one level of so like whenever
you have x1 square you
introduce it by replacing a new variable
and then
in a lifted space you see that those
multilinear sets
um we consider different number of
variables
uh different sparsity patterns
uh and then different number of
constraints so actually i should say
it's not even unconstrained polynomial
optimization you also have inequalities
that are polynomials okay
now what we do is uh for
for each combination we generate a bunch
of random instances so
we are doing the following so we want to
solve these problems to global
optimality
there are a bunch of solvers out there
for mixed integer non-linear problems
so we want to measure or we want to show
the impact of the inequalities that i
told you
in expediting the convergence rate of
this
solver for general problems the problem
is that they don't have any kind of a
simplicity you see it's even like
you have constraints things are
continuous
so you just want to use those
inequalities at cutting planes inside
the branch unbound approach
so here we are using one of those
solvers that is called baron
branch and reduce optimization navigator
it is a commercial solver it's available
under
i'd say gams ample matlab
so you can use it it's also available
for free on neos
here we used it under gams um
so we are again we are just measuring
so we solve given an and a polynomial
optimization problem
i solve it under two settings baron
default and then baron
with the cuts running intersection cuts
added to it
and these cuts are included every in
every node in the branch and boundary
you solve the cheap relaxation then
you look you get the solution you solve
the separation problem over that point
meaning that
does this point satisfy that running
intersection inequalities no if not
give me some that violates it you add it
to the relaxation
you solve it again so here i'm measuring
the impact
with respect to the cpu time number of
nodes
in the branch and boundary and memory
requirements
so you can see width cuts on the
horizontal axis and without cuts on the
vertical axis and you you get
like 50 reduction in compute in cpu time
which is
pretty good because the solver is
already very well developed so there are
a ton of things
going on there so this is for polynomial
optimization problems of degree 3.
here's a study for degree 4. you see
similar improvements
um this is pretty much these are the
measures that we are hoping to see
improvement for when we
you know work on this kind of solvers
and then finally here's an application
this is a problem in a computer vision
it's called
image restoration so you have a blurred
image and you
want to uh understand what was the
original image that can be written
as an unconstrained polynomial
optimization of degree four
so unconstrained zero one polynomial
optimization of degree four
if you look at the hyper graph of these
guys they are not even better acyclic
so they have better cycles if you put
the running intersection cuts in barren
you can see that the improvement is even
more than the random problems you can
see more than 60 percent uh
cpu time reduction and again this is
just to show you
even though in this case these
inequalities are not enough to
characterize the convex hull
adding them to the relaxation leads to
better bounds better bounds
mean faster convergence in general
and indeed this is the case here
so let's see okay that's pretty much it
and here are a number of papers that we
wrote over the years
if you are interested about the details
you can take a look and of course if you
have any questions you can
always email me thank you
thanks a lot i know i'm doing the
you know the collective round of
applause for everybody on zoom
uh this is this is great
again it's it's a it's a great
opportunity for us to to learn a little
bit about
um what's going on on the other side uh
uh over in mixed interlinear uh
and non-linear optimization uh again i
think there's a lot of
room for more communication between this
community and the sat community and i'm
very happy that we had this seminar
um i could certainly think of a bunch of
questions but this you've already heard
so i should maybe give the opportunity
to others to ask their questions first
so or if people are thinking so one
thing that i'm
curious about is
oh so i guess this is something that
works well for
inequalities if i had equalities
is there any comparison on on these kind
of methods or just throwing like a
gramner basis solver at it
so by inequalities you mean
in the original set or yeah suppose that
my original
like suppose my original problem was a
set of equalities
uh then i get then they're sort of just
multi-linear polynomials and i was just
curious whether i guess i could feed
such a problem either to like
baron or something similar or yeah or i
could try to pick a good
grabner basis solver from the
computational algebra people
and see how that does is that like do
you ever compare against such
i have not um for in case of
uh mixed into journal linear programming
solvers as long as you can write it
as a problem of maximizing minimizing an
objective function
subject to a bunch of constraints
equality inequality so you have an
algebraic description you can input it
to baron
now of course that doesn't mean that
because the co
it's basically the proof of this
algorithms it will at some point
converge
so how fast it converges it's really
depends on the
very specific structure of the problem
and unfortunately it's also very a
function of how you exactly input the
problem because as you can see this
convexification like that recursive
technique that i told you how to
introduce new variables
and you know get this that very much so
you can take the same problem
and just write it in like factor
something out and then write it down
the quality it the solver might become
much slower or faster
um so just the short answers i haven't
done the comparison but you can input
certainly those problems in
um unfortunate these solvers are general
unfortunately they still require a lot
of
um user expertise so you should kind of
i mean they are getting better but it's
not like convex optimization
so you should know a little bit about
how they work to
make sure that you use them to their
full potential
let me see it makes sense
oh yeah if you ever want to use bear i
should do a little bit of maybe
advertisement because yes
the owner of baron is my former phd
advisor and i worked
on it for quite a few years i'm not
actively working on it anymore but
in case you have any question about how
to using it you can always email me
and how does this compare to i mean to
to what extent
are these capabilities that also i guess
when you
start talking about mib solving you know
the people drop names like
cplex gorby express
so um it well i think it's
well i don't know what ambrose voice
would say but i say baron is the state
of the art
um there are a few others uh
well yeah i let ambrose too
i'm biased so i'm in the barren team um
or like mortal enemies or something oh
no they're friends skip
actually it's great skip is open source
byron is not open source i should say
that it's commercial
i i think that skip and baron have a bit
different
strengths i mean baron like for very
non-linear problems is definitely the
state of the art in outperform skip i
would say especially if you don't have
integer variables um if you have like a
large mip component
then i could imagine that sometimes skip
still can outperform baron but i mean
this depends on the application yeah
so you could you know at this point you
could just give all of them a try and
hope
for your first luck you know because
these problems are at the end difficult
problems so
you know when people like oh you do
non-comics optimization i have this
problem with a few thousand variables
and to them a few thousand is nothing
i'm like yeah sorry
okay so so you're saying like the
nonlinear problems they get hard pretty
quickly yes but also there is no
i mean for example how you measure
difficulty it's not very clear
so it's not just the scale it really
depends on the type of non-convexity
but yeah i mean i must say again because
you know
i worked on baron when i was a student
that was long time ago i worked a bit
after
now i'm not so involved into
computations
so i might be very outdated but
the times i was involved in it yeah but
as amara said baron's
strength was a lot into non-convex
non-linear problems
from what i know there has been a lot of
new developments
in the mip part of it now but i really
don't know how it compares with skip
but another new one of coming solver in
this space is gurubi
so i heard people talk about that a lot
especially for mixed integer quadratic
problems
and there are like a group of new people
working on it
um so that could be also a potential
competitor
for future it's a final high-level
question
to to to you either maybe also to
ambrose like from from the
mips side of things is there any
um like interest in or outreach to
other communities like like constraint
programming or i don't know
satisfiability modulo theories or
something like anything that you see
there that like
this is cool this would like to import
or or is it
like or in general any thoughts about
like potential for interaction or
or maybe not so much like you have your
techniques and they work for the
problems you need to solve
so in baron it's called branch and
reduce because
at least when it was developed there's a
lot of constraint programming going on
inside and i so one thing that i didn't
talk at all
about is so when you construct these
lower bounds the the tighter the
bounds on variables the smaller the
domain the better the quality
so they do a lot of techniques from
constraint programming as pre-processing
to you know
filter the domain like the things that
you guys say
so some of those things are already
there um
uh the only person i know who is
actively working at the intersection is
john hooker a temper who does constraint
programming and
optimization both
yeah i don't know ambrose are we trying
to reaching out to the
constraint programmers
um i think not not hugely as a community
i would say but uh
individual people do i think there's a
lot of constraint
um programming in skip two right
uh yes i mean the conflict analysis is
something that's definitely inspired by
saturn through the boolean solving and i
think that's
still not the end of what is possible
yeah yeah um
yeah so i think i'm looking if there are
any
final questions in the chat what we
already
i mean we should let you off the hook
you've been
talking to us for quite some time now uh
just uh i put a reminder in the in the
chat that
all registered workshop participants are
welcome to meet
um at gather town uh
[Music]
so um
and i guess we uh with that i think we
can conclude today's seminar
uh so aydah again thank you so much
and thank you thank you so much for
having me
thank you very much thank you
thank you very much